[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
let's bring in Ross chucker CBS Westwood
one color analyst host of the Ross
Tucker football podcast let me start
with Dallas what do you think they will
do what do you think they should do
I think they will stick with Cooper Rush
Dan and I think that's probably what
they should do if you think about it
right from the perspective of the 49ers
not only what you referenced about the
Niners probably wanting to keep Jimmy G
in their back pocket and see a little
bit more of Trey Lance
but one of the reasons why the Niners
reworked his deal ban is because when
Jimmy leaves this off season as a free
agent I think we all assume he'll
probably get a starting job somewhere
because there's a bunch of teams that
could probably use him well that means
he's going to get paid enough money that
the Niners get a third round
compensatory pick so if you're the
Niners there's no reason to trade Jimmy
now unless you get something better than
a third round compensatory pick are the
cowboys really going to give a second
round pick for four weeks of Jimmy
Garoppolo because it would take him a
week or two to get ramped up you make a
good point about you know his health not
only that the Cowboys are not a good
team right now I I part of me wonders if
Jimmy would even want to go there and
start for four to six weeks behind a bad
team bad offensive line they don't have
very many weapons so it doesn't seem to
make sense for anyone it's a shame
because it feels like the Cowboys season
is kind of almost over before it even
starts but I think they're gonna just
stand Pat with Cooper Rush doesn't make
sense from my standpoint for either the
Niners or the Cowboys to make that trade
so it's going to be Cooper rush time
maybe they can win a couple games but
they're not very good I mean on some
level Dan it almost gives the Cowboys a
built-in excuse for a season I think was
already going to be disappointing anyway
but they are the Cowboys and that's why
we hype them up people at Dak Prescott
MVP candidate Mike McCarthy maybe going
to be Coach of the Year why lofty
expectations with the Cowboys
well just because they're the Cowboys
and uh they're the biggest National
brand I guess I'm assuming with the
Yankees in our country from a sports
standpoint you know I don't know I gotta
look Dan and see how many nationally
televised games they have coming up
because we gotta we gotta find a way to
flex out of those okay well I'm going to
tune in to see Micah Parsons I I will
tune in to watch Micah Parsons can Micah
Parsons play quarterback
they should try it at this point look
Dan he grew up he literally grew up uh
like
half a mile that way from where I'm
sitting right now I saw his third High
School game ever Dan when he was a
freshman
and he had like four or five sacks and I
texted the guy at Penn State I know I go
uh you need to look at this ninth grader
at Central Dauphin High School they
offered him a scholarship day in the
next week he got a he got his first
scholarship after three High School
football games you should have seen him
as a running back he looked like Jim
Brown I mean he was like the Jim Brown
as a running back around here it was
amazing all right if you ran the Niners
do you stay with what you have you keep
Trey Lance in there and you keep Jimmy
Garoppolo
how long does the experiment last with
Trey Lance before you start to get a
little nervous that maybe Jimmy
Garoppolo gives you a better chance
this is actually one of the reasons why
I was a little bit skeptical of them
keeping Jimmy I think this helps them to
have a better backup option it gives
them more ability to maybe trade Jimmy
if someone like the Cowboys came with
something but sort of the omnipresent
threat now of Garoppolo hangover Lance's
shoulder it's not good then I mean the
kid only played one year of FCS football
it's actually amazing that a guy can
play one year as a redshirt freshman of
FCS football and be the third pick in
the draft you would have told me that
would ever happen but he just hasn't
played that much so if you're the Niners
and you're really looking at this thing
the right way I think you got to keep
Trey Lance in there until you're almost
out of it I mean I think it's got to be
at least six weeks and he's gonna play
better he's going to get better I mean I
hope we're not spending too much time
judging a kid by how he played in his
first game in an absolute monsoon soon
yeah I agree I just wonder and I
mentioned this last week because I had a
source who told me Jay Glazer reported
it yesterday and that is there are
veterans in that locker room
who had to be told be all in and support
Trey Lance because some of those
veterans realize at least from what I
was told Jimmy Garoppolo will give them
a better chance to go further this
season whether that's you know how many
or not but that is something that I
think is is the underlying current there
and then that's a real thing okay I can
remember distinctly after the 0-4 season
in Buffalo where we went nine and two
like our last 11 games or whatever we
were really excited going into the next
season
they either cut or traded blood cell I
can't remember which one and I remember
calling some of the veterans some of the
other starters on the offensive line and
they were like that's it I'm not going
up there once all off season they moved
on from blood tail to go to JP lostman
and it was so deflating Dan it was like
we had a chance to make a run go to the
playoffs and you just knew you weren't
going to be as good with JP you just
knew it and that's got to be tough and I
know you know garoppolo's friends with a
lot of those guys he hangs out with like
use check and Kittle and those guys that
is tough to swallow when you've been to
a Super Bowl and on the precipice of
another Super Bowl and you feel like
you're a Super Bowl caliber team the
fact that they had to say that to them
that Glazer's reporting that it seems
like the Niners players know that even
if Trey Lance gets better it's still not
realistic for them to have a chance to
go to the Super Bowl it's more of a
transition year a rebuilding year that's
tough to give up when you're in the
middle or towards the end of your career
it's tough to just have a give up year
or a year where you probably realize
deep down you don't really have a chance
to win the whole thing
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyst playing for a tie or going for
two
I love what the Giants did
even before the play the fact that they
were going to go for two and go for the
win loved it then you have the Texans
who played for a tie
help me understand the philosophy with
these two organizations that Lovey Smith
doesn't and Brian dabel does go for two
well first of all it's an absolute
travesty that there are ties I I I can't
tell you Dan you know how many man hours
go in each week for these games and when
you tie nobody gets to fuel their reward
when you tie both teams feel like they
lost it's not mission accomplished when
you tie a game it's awful you know the
day ball thing is interesting because
it ended up working out but really if
you think about going for two there
right
it's 50 50 whether or not you get it and
then even if you do get it and you're up
by one the Titans are then going to be
much more aggressive offensively to make
sure they get in field goal range
because they're losing and there's a
decent chance you still lose anyway
now fortunately for the Giants Bullock
missed the kick and it worked out yeah
but they're very fortunate on a lot I
mean saquon Barkley was dead to rights
in the backfield that was an amazing job
by him the Lovey Smith one I'll never
understand and his comment after the
game was like well we didn't really have
much of a chance to win anymore so I
didn't want to have a chance to lose hey
lovey was fourth down and whatever it
was fourth and not even that long
Midfield that that's I'll I'll tell you
this much Dan
two first-year head coaches
win or lose the Giants players love the
fact that Dave ball went for it win or
lose none of them will say it publicly
or in this case Tai
the Texans players they're not happy
with Lobby Smith they would have wanted
to go for it not a single player would
be like you know coach I was thinking
about it and it actually was a good
tactical decision that you decided to
punt it so that we didn't look no no
they want to win the game what does
Lovie Smith think it's going to happen
Dan does Lovie Smith think that the
Texans are going to be 10 6 and 1 and
that that ties the difference from
making the playoffs or not what's he
even doing
Ross Tucker joining us on behalf of
DraftKings
um I'm I'm watching the Bengals
and I'm watching Joe burrow
now I'm trying not to overreact but Joe
burrow played the position as if he
didn't know how to play the position and
I know that he was coming off surgery
you're going against a divisional
opponent that has a very good defense
how to how do Bengal fans Not Over React
to what they saw in that loss to the
Steelers
well they don't overreact because if
they could make an extra point and it
didn't get blocked they still would have
won right so that that that's where they
find some comfort and solace in the loss
but you know the thing for me
they have a whole new offensive line
he got sacked seven times now this was
actually my big critique of burrow last
year and why I don't think he's as good
as other people do I don't think he's a
top five guy yet Dan he takes a lot of
sacks he takes some sacks that he
shouldn't take and then yesterday he
combined that with the four
interceptions one to pick six he fumbled
as well it was rough and now for the
Bengals offensive line they're gonna
need to come to I mean they're all new
so that that'll take a little bit of
time the Steelers had some pretty good
Blitz packages that the Bengals
struggled with they'll be fine I really
do think the Bengals will be fine
good to talk to you as always always
thank you so much Dan all right that's
Ross Tucker joining us on behalf of
DraftKings DraftKings Sportsbook app you
can download it make sure you use the
promo code Patrick get 200 in free bets
instantly place a five dollar bet on any
football game so the promo code is
Patrick only at DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL